ونحييكم من جديد تمجد الارهاب والتحريض
على قوات الامن والاساءه لاجهزه الدوله
تهم واجهت بها محكمه تونسيه زعيمه حركه
النهضه راشد الغنوشي حيث امرت دائره
الجنائيه المختصه بالنظر في قضايا الارهاب
تونس بالسجن مده عام بحق الغنوشي مع غرامه
ماليه وقدرها الف دينار تونسي القضيه تعود
لفبراير من العام الماضي وكان رفعها ضد
الغنوشي لقبي امني بعد وصف زعيم النهضه
الامهين بالطواقيط خلال تابين عضوي مجلس
الشورى في حركه النهضه فرحات الغبار تم
الحكم بسجن الغنوشي في هذه القضيه رغم
رفضه حضور جلسات المحاكمه وامتناعه عن
مغادره مكان توقيفه بسجن المرناجيه للوصول
امام القضاء السلطات التونسيه كانت اوقفت
الغنوشي منذ نحو ثلاثه اسابيع بتهمه
التامر على امن الدوله الداخلي على خلفيه
تصريح هدد فيه باشعال حرب اهليه وباثاره
الف في حاله ابعاد الحركه من السلطه ولكن
الحكم لم يكن الاول فقبل اسبوع صدر حكم
اخر بسجن الغنوشي بتهمن تتعلق بتبييض
الاموال والاعتداء على امن الدوله ولو ان
هذا لم يكن حكم هذا كان بطاقه ايداع كما
ان الغنوشي ليس وحده فالى جانبه تقبع
قياده بارزه في حركه النهضه في السجون
لمواجهتهم شبهات متعدده من بينها التامر
على امن الدوله والتورط في شبكات التسفير
الى بؤر التوتر
نتابع هذا الموضوع بالنقاش مع ضيوفنا من
تونس خليل الرقيق الاعلامي والمحلل
السياسي ومن تونس كذلك الاستاذ عماد بن
حليمه القانوني والناشط السياسي اهلا بكم
ضيوفي الكرام واسمحوا لي ان ابدا مع
الاستاذ عماد بن حليمه استاذ عماد نقطه
نظام او نقطه توضيح
كل ما سبق كان بطاقات ايداع هذا اول حكم
في حق راشد الغنوشي صحيح
نعم تحيه ليك والى كل متابعي قناه العربيه
طبعا هذا الحكم هو اول الحكم لان في
الايقافات السابقه هنالك بطاقه ايداع اولى
على خلفيه ما صرح به وما اعتبر دعوه
للاقتتال وحينما صرح وان
اباده الاسلام السياسي بتونس سيؤدي الى
الحرب الاهليه هنالك بطاقه ايداع ثانيه
صدرت في حقه في القضيه التحقيقيه المنشوره
امام المحكمه الابتدائيه سوسه اثنين فيما
يعرف بقضيه انستالينغو وهي قضيه تشمل
التامر على امن الدوله وكذلك تبييض
الاموال هذا اول الحكم يصدر ويصدر عن
دائره جناحيه لانه لما نرجع الى قانون
الارهاب اوت 2017 ان التمجيد الارهابي
يعني التفاخر بالعمليات الارهابيه هو من
قبيل الجنحه التي يعاقب فيها القانون
بالسجن من سنه الى خمس سنوات
غنوشي احيل على الدائره الجناحيه وهذا
الحكم فيه رمزيه لانه اول حكم يصدر بالسجن
ضد الغنوشي يكون في قضيه ذات طبع ارهابي
وهذا فيه ترميز
كبير ولا يمكن انا استمعت اليوم الى بعض
الى البيان الذي اصدرته حركه الاخوان
بتونس وكذلك الى بعض تصريحات فريق الدفاع
الحقيقه لا يمكن المرور لمناقشه هل ان
الامر يتعلق بتمجيد الارهاب ام لا يتعلق
بتمجيد الارهاب هل ان استعمال عباره
الطاغوت التي استعملها الغنوشي كان يقصد
بها الارهاب كل هذا نقاش
الامن طالما
طالما وان راشد الغنوشي احنا نعرف ان
الغنوشي اتخذ قرارا فيما سبق واعلن عنه
فريق دفاع لان لا يتحول للبحث الاولي لدى
الفرق الامنيه وهذا تقريب من حقوق الدفاع
ان لا يمثل الجاني امام الفرق الامنيه على
انه التزم بالمثول امام القضاء في هذه
القضيه وجه استدعال للسجن لاحضار الغنوشي
بالجلسه التي كانت مقرره النظر فيها في
الملف الغنوشي رفض المثول امام المحكمه
وحينما يرفض المتهم المثول
بطريقه مباشره في تونس يتم توقيفه هو
ايداعه السجن
هو في لما رفض المثل في هذه القضيه التي
حكم فيها اليوم
من يترك يترك هذا الشخص لم يحضر ولم يدافع
عن نفسه فلا مجال للحديث على ان الحكم كان
جائرا او لم يكن في طريقه او كان يستهدفه
هو حر هو رفض المثول اما لسبب انه يرفض ان
يحاكم او لسبب
لضيق الوقت ساعود لك بخصوص هذه القضيه
وحضرتك كنت لك جمله ساتوقف عندها قلت
بالتعبير التونسي اللي يحب يلعب يكمل
اللعبه للاخر يعني من يريد اللعب مع
القذافه ليكمل هذه ساعود لك لتعلق لي لانك
وكانك
تشكك في اراده الغنوش ولكن اسمح لي ان
نشرك معنا الاستاذ خليل استاذ خليل
بيان النهضه ومؤيدي النهضه في تونس
اعتبروا بان هذا الحكم حكم مسيس حتى بانه
قيل بان النظام الحالي في تونس يجهز
محاكمات حاضره جاهزه هل هذا دقيق
في الحقيقه يعني هذا الكلام غير دقيق
بالمره يعني حركه النهضه عن ماذا تتحدث عن
حكم سياسي مجهز والحال انه كما كان يقول
رجل القانون امامنا الان ان هذه الجريمه
فيها فصول قانونيه جريمه التحريض على
الارهاب فيها فصول قانونيه واضحه لها
عقوبه واضحه وان هذه الجريمه هذه المره
تمت فقط في زمن قضاء قياسي وهذا مهم هذه
التطورات شهدتها الساحه القضائيه منذ 25
جوليا 2021 ولكن هي قضيه بسيطه جدا هذه
الكلمات المفاتيح التي يحيل تحيلها حركه
النهضه الى التناصر القراني ويحيلها اخرون
الى التصريحات وحريه التعبير هي كلمات
لابد ان نستحضر فيها المقارنه التاريخيه
القاضيه يعيش بيننا القاضي التونسي يعرف
ان استعمال هذه المصطلحات من طرف
الاسلاميين في فترات معينه يعني الانتقال
من مرحله التعبير السياسي لهذا الى مرحله
التصادم فعل ذلك الغنوشي في 91 وانتهينا
بجريمه باب السويقه المرو
سوره البقره انزلت على رسول وصوره قرانيه
والغنوشي ليس رسولا الغنوشي السياسي وكلمه
الطاغوت كما قلت لك الامني الذي رفع
القضيه كان ذلك على خلفيه احساسه بان
رفاقه الذين ماتوا في مواجهات مع
الارهابيين ماتوا بهذه الكلمه المفتاح
استعمال كلمه التواغيت هي ملعب حصري
للجماعات الارهابيه صارت تستعمل مع
مصطلحات اخرى مثل الديار الكفر والكفره
وغيرها للانتقام او التسيد في اجهزه
الدوله تحديدا وهي الامن والجيش هذه
الكلمه المفتاح كانت سببا في ضياع حياه
عشرات الامنيين وعشرات العسكريين في تونس
اذا يمكن الفهم منها والغنوصي ليس شخصا
عاديا كما قلنا
انها كانت نوعا من تحرير المبادره او ربما
نوعا من الرساله وليست العباره التي جعلت
الاخوان يمررون من مرحله الجهاز العالمي
القانوني الى مرحله اجهزه اخرى غير مرئيه
لا نراها الا
عندما يخرج الغنوشي من السلطه ولكن اليوم
يعني السؤال يطرح نفسه العديد يقولون
لماذا حسب الغنوشي حول التصريح ولم تعجل
محاسبته في خلايا اخرى كبرى موجوده على
ذمتها الان وموده على ذمتها نقول انه
ببساطه هذه القضيه ليست قضيه شائكه
الاحاله فيها واضحه وسهله هي قضيه تصريح
فيها مكافحه والزمان القضائي
الاخرى تتواجد تحقيق اطول صحيح صحيح فهمت
تتوجب تحقيق اطول هذه التخطيط وضحت الفكره
استاذ عماد هل تشكك في نوايا الغنوشي او
في اهدافه من عدم الامتثال قلت حضرتك بانه
ان اراد ان يلعب فليكمل لعبه للاخر البعض
قراها على ان الغنوشي يود من عدم الامتثال
حبسه وبالتالي اعاده احياء اسم النهضه
اعاده
استعطاف قاعدته ام انه حضرتك قص د شيء اخر
انا احضر في الاول من شيء مهم انا ضد
رسكلت المجرمين الى ضحايا انا اريد
المحاسبه المحاسبه في الملفات الكبرى في
ملفات التسفير في ملفات نشر الارهاب في
ملفات استنزاف المال العام ولا اريد ان
تكون هذه المحاكمات فرصه لتحويل المجرمين
الى ضحايا ونشر ثقافه المظلوميه من جديد
الغنوشي رفض اليوم المثول امام المحكمه
بعد ان تعهد من سابق بالمثور امام الجهات
القضائيه يعني احد الامرين اما انه يحتج
على محاكمته او انه يرى ان القضاء اليوم
قضاء غير مستقل وقضايا يعمل تحت ابره قيس
سعيد وينفذ اجنده سياسيه في كلتا الحالتين
مادام رفض المثول وصدر الحكم معتبرا
حضوريا والحكم المعتبر حضوري هو قابل
للاستئناف ونستمعت بعض الاعضاء من فريق
الدفاع يوضحونه وان هذا الحكم قابل
للاستئناف انا ادعو لغنوشي الى ان يكون
مفترسلا ومنطقيا ولا يطعن في الحكم
بالاستئناف لانه على فكره
غير مستقل
ان يخضع الى تنفيذ هذا الحكم هو حتى في
خصوص هذا الموضوع كان هناك تباين في
الاراء سمير ديلو يقول بانه سنستانف الحكم
الشاب يقول احمد الشاب يقول بانه لن يكون
هناك اعتراف ولن نستانف الحكم احمد شابي
طبعا في جبهه الخلاص التي تضم كذلك انها
تعتقد بانه
اريد ان اشدد على نقطه للتوضيح راهو في
الاجراءات هنالك قواعد هنالك قاعده اصوليه
في الاجراءات الجزائيه تقول ان الغياب هو
عبس
انت لا تحذر لا تدافع عن نفسك ليس لك ان
تهاجم المحكمه لا يمكن للمحكمه ان تعطيك
حقوقا اكثر من الحقوق التي منحتك اياه
ورفضت ممارسته
باختصار شديد ما الذي سيترتب على هذا
الحكم
شعبيا اتحدث
باختصار شديد في الحقيقه الذي يترتب الذي
يترتب عن هذا الحكم شعبيا هو موجه من
الارتياح لان المطالبه بمساله المحاسبه
القضائيه لجرائم حركه النهضه هي مطلب شعبي
عام وليست فقط مطلبا نخبوين المطلبا
سياسيا اليوم نحن امام قضايا قلنا من
السهل تناولها الراي العام ينتظر الان
انكشاف الحقائق المريعه والتي تبدو من
خلال التحقيقات مريعه حول
شكرا جزيل الشكر الاستاذ خليل والاستاذ
عماد شكرا جزيلا لكم السلام عليكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات